[music]
[music] [music]
]
[Music]
[Applause]
[  Music]
Welcome to the TGS2022 Capcom Online Program
This program will provide information on Capcom's latest
titles.
We will deliver 12 latest information
First, please watch the latest promotion video
here
[Music]
[Applause]
Free  Title Update 2nd
Version 12
will be released on Thursday, September 29th.
From here
on, I will tell you the details of the update. Please enjoy it until the end
.
[Music]
[Applause]
This rare species
uses its own synovial fluid to glide
and manipulate gas-filled bubbles to corner the
target.
If it decides to eliminate it with , it
will wear flames on its body
and turn the surrounding area into a sea of ​​flames with fierce movements.Then, the far-
left Espinus Ashgar will appear, resurrected from Monster Hunter Frontier.
Its most distinctive feature is the
dress it unleashes after accumulating all its strength.It is said
that its willingness is enough to exhaust a hunter with a single blow
.  The ancient dragons that have been confirmed to appear will
use new actions and forms
to launch more devastating attacks against
hunters.
Rare Tamamitsune species and Espinus subspecies are
Master Rank 10 or higher
Simple Overcoming Owners are Master Rank
110 or higher The quest will be released. Please look forward
to
new weapons and armor created from the materials, as well as
new skills
[Music]
Version 12 or later  A
brief introduction to the content of the update related to the relationship survey quest
EX-star 6 for simple quests will be
released, and monsters such as Gore Magala and S Pinus
will be added.
You can enjoy
bargaining with monsters with feelings.
[Applause]
[Music] Starting
this time,
a new layered breath system will be implemented.
Weapon appearances can now be layered
, and almost all weapons up to version 12 will
appear as layers in your
favorite combinations.
[Music] We
will continue to add new paid downloadable content
in the future.
We have stamps, etc.
Event quests are also being distributed every week
[Music]
Other update outlines are
scheduled to be released on SNS and the official website,
so
please wait for information updates
[Music]
Monster Hunter Rise 3 Break
Version 12
will be delivered on Thursday, September 29th. The
next version 13 is
scheduled to be updated in late November, and will
continue to be updated in 2023.
Please stay tuned for information on Monster Hunter Rise 3 Break
.  Music]
[Music]
Next, we will deliver the latest information on the Resident Evil series
.
Hello everyone
, this is
Kanda, the producer of
Resident Evil Village.
draw the final of
This
title has sold over 6.5 million copies worldwide and has become a huge hit
.
First of all, please take a look at the latest gameplay video
The first content of the additional DLC
is the third person mode, which was requested by many fans
.
Of course, you can see plenty of his movements, and
you can also feel the fear unique to the third-person view.
Battles are
more familiar to series fans than the original.
Unique action
Let's make good use of the limited resources and survive from the desperate situation
Next is the new city
Shadows of Nose
This can also be played from the third person perspective
16 years after the main story
Mr. E's daughter
Rose's grown up  Survival is depicted
The world of consciousness, which is the stage, is
terrifyingly unreal
Various strange creatures are
seeking Rose's sacred land and are closing in. In
this world, just one damage can
be fatal
[Applause]
[Music]
Secret  Rose is troubled by the power she has been given, but in this world
, that power is of great help.
The
Mercenaries Additional Orders Additions to The Mercenaries,
where you can enjoy unique gameplay
Additional stages
Additional playable characters join the battle, and
game modes and evolutions with even more heavy play volume
[Applause] Unique additional characters
such as Dmitrescu and Heisenberg stand out
even in the series  The
set of
the additional DLC
Winter's Expansion introduced
this time and the additional DLC Resident Evil
Village
Gold Edition will be released on October 28th.
As a
limited bonus,
we will present Nose's costume and street wolf outfit that can be used in the additional scenario Shadows of Rose
Please make a reservation Please make a reservation
!
Hazard Village will be
released in 2022. By
supporting Apple silicon, we were able
to express delicate graphics powerfully.It
can be
played not only on MacBook but also
on all MACs equipped with M1 and M2 chips.The
compatible models are on the official website.
We would like as many people as possible
to enjoy the Resident Evil series, so we
have decided to distribute the
Nintendo
Switch cloud version.
Appears in a cloud version that allows you to play while connected to the Internet
Game fans who have never had a village play environment before
can now play.
A trial version that
allows you to check the operation
of the cloud version is also being distributed The cloud version on the Nintendo Switch is scheduled to be distributed as
Resident Evil 7 Resident Evil RE2
Resident Evil RE3
Resident Evil 7 Cloud
version is expected to be played indefinitely
[Music]
The Resident Evil Village we've introduced so far is now
exhibiting a
playable version of the PlayStation VR2 version at the Tokyo Game Show 2022 Capcom
booth.
Please come visit us at
the Capcom
booth.
Thank you very
much.  We
have been developing Resident Evil RE4 for the latest generation of consoles, including PlayStation 5, but
we have also continued to consider it for the current
world.
I would like to tell you that it will be compatible with PlayStation 4. In
addition to the latest information on Resident Evil RE4,
we will be presenting the Resident Evil Showcase next month.
See
you all at the
Resident Evil Showcase Now,
here
's the latest information on Capcom's new action title, Exo Primal.
Please
[music]
[applause]
How was it?
I would like to introduce the latest information included in a little more
detail.This work is set in the
year 2040
A.D.In a world where a group of shared people suddenly appear and attack the townspeople of a
shared disaster, a shared disaster occurs.
He decides to become a pilot,
and in the year 2043,
when the carrier piloted by the protagonists gets
caught up in a gigantic vortex and crash-
lands on an island while introducing the surroundings of Liquid Art, the story
begins to take a major turn.
A battle between dinosaurs and exo fighters that appear beyond the game time and space
Players are caught up in the war game and
will challenge Ikuta's mission presented by Mr. Iwaya
for survival.  As you play, you will
gradually unravel the story.From
here,
we will introduce the characters who are deeply involved in the
story.First of all, the main character
is nicknamed Ace by
his
friends.He is the player's alter ego, and
his appearance can be customized through character creation.
It is
the stage Hammerheads to which the main character belongs.
Let's take a look at the members as well.
Drenzo, a first-class suit mechanic who acts as the leader of the stage
. He is called the chief by the crew.
It
's the Android Sandy who plays a support role in the squad.We also introduce
the key people in this story where the four meet
in
one.The exosuit pilot Magnum who tells us the situation on Bihitoa Island and
how to survive the wargame.The
other is the
Watcher.  Darman is a mysterious figure who seems to be following him.
How will they be involved?
And in this video, a
new exosuit has appeared.
His role is a tank.
He guards against attacks from all directions with mixed extinguishing and uses
a counter to eliminate the enemy
.
The Skywave Doll, which flies in the sky like an aether dance
and attacks and recovers,
is a support.
The Octix Jammer, which obstructs the enemy's vision, is effective not only for sharing, but also for the enemy team's exosuit
.
In
addition, blades have appeared as rigs that can be attached to exosuits.
Of course, we can't forget about them. The
new dinosaur in this video
is an automatic saurus that looks like a ruff
.  Visibility on the field gets
worse,
making it difficult to fight
Carnotaurus is a dinosaur with a large body, but it is
a fast-moving dinosaur.
It's an expected neotyrannosaurus
It's an individual with overwhelming attack power
There are other exosuit-rigged dinosaurs out there
, so please wait for future announcements
Now from here  Let
me explain how to customize your exosuit
Hammerheads have a hangar in their carrier,
where you
can change the look of your suit skins and weapon skins Decals and charms, etc.
Customize your suit
Emotes and stamps can be set
Communication wheel
Enhances the durability of your suit.
Weapon reload speed can be increased, and even modules that
change the performance of active skills for each suit
are possible.Items that
can be used for customization
are modules.
There are various ways to obtain suits, such as raising the level of the suit,
but the
more you play the game, the more you can obtain
them.
This work will be
released in 2023. We are working hard to prepare
it for release
.
Please look forward to it.
The Rockman EXE series, which is
still loved by many fans, is still connected.
The
10 numbered works will
be revived on NintendoSWITCH PlayStation 4 Steam
Rockman EXE
Advanced Collection Released in 2023 Software as an additional function in the Advanced Collection
High image quality that can be switched to a different drawing
Equipped with filters and a
gallery mode with a
total of over 1000 illustrations and
188 in-game BGM
included Music player included In addition,
the title selection screen that reproduces the [Music] head screen
3D Rockman is
in charge of navigating with
a voice.Various reactions will be returned depending on the play situation
and operations.And
we have received comments from the director of this work, Master Eguchi
.
I'm a master Rockman EXE Advance has returned to the stage of TGS!
It's been about 17 years since the 6th collection EXE,
and I'm very happy to be able to share
EXE information with everyone again.  By the way, everyone
, there is something that you are really curious about.
Yes
, please rest assured about
the communication function
.  But I'm going to connect you all
I
really
want to talk about the white coat that was beautifully repaired, but that's all I can tell you this time.
Master Thank You In
this work, in addition to the advantageous advanced collection containing 10 works including version differences
from the first Rockman EXE to Rockman
EXE 6
,
Volume 1 and Volume 2, which divides the recorded content into two, are also
distributed.  Please check
the
official website and
Mega Man series official Twitter for product details and future
updates.
Street
Fighter 6 was announced in June, but
thank you for the many responses
.
Today we will deliver the latest information. First of all
,
please watch
the video.  ]
[Applause]
[Music]
How did you like it?
Street Fighter 6 has 3 main modes in the World
Tour
Fighting Ground Battle Hub
.
You've seen the four characters.It's already night.First of all, it's Dhalsim, the master of yoga.In this game, he's a character who
manipulates his long reach and fire skills
to attack
tricks.The chest accessories and costumes are new.
It's designed
Enough and break
Next, I
'm Hedmond Honda, a hot-blooded sumo wrestler.I'll fight with
dynamic strength and urban power.Metro
CityIt seems that I opened Sumo Chaya Edmon, a place where you can enjoy sumo and chanko nabe
.
Blanka, the warrior of nature, will also make an
appearance
. He is a tour guide on Amazon
.
Finally, the dragon's rival sword appears.
There is a big change in appearance, but what
kind of story is there?
[Music]
Have you seen the variations?
You can also learn special moves and
expand the range of battles
Street Fighter 6 incorporates many new play elements, including new
characters and familiar
characters from the series
.
I think there was a scene with the field.This is
a new battle content called Extreme Battle.You
can fight by combining the
rules that determine the outcome and gimmicks that appear during the
battle.  For
example, you can select a bomb gimmick that bounces when you hit it.The
battle will be based on unique rules, so
I think you'll be able to experience a different experience
than usual.  Please look forward to it
Nextis
new information about the automatic commentary function.
Let's
make it rain and increase our firepower
[music]
I'm going to step back and hit it
firmly I
'm going
to decide on an unexpected just that I can't turn over
I'll show you what's called a bloodline
Fight to annihilate your whole body
I guess you could see what I'm doing now I'm
more satisfied with myself  Let
's see, there's a good one.It's
as funny as
hell.I've been able to tell you that this is sumo wrestling.I'm
looking forward to the battles to
come.So again, Mr.
Hirai, who is known as an E-sports caster
, agreed with Kousuke.
His easy-to-understand and polite commentary will definitely make the match lively. And the commentator was approved by His Excellency
Damon.
In 6,
we are working hard
to ensure that a wide variety of people can participate in the game,
so please look forward to future announcements
.
You can enjoy your own story in this world by what kind of indicators you learn from.The
character that will be your alter ego uses the editing function that incorporates the technology
cultivated through the development experience of various Kakone titles.
Let's take a look at the actual character making here.
Not only height and body shape, but also
muscle mass and wrinkles,
you can make a character with attention to detail.
By purchasing and
equipping, you will be able to express your individuality more.In addition to the
appearance,
equipping will change the performance of your character.If
you
start in this town, start
from the
streets.
Battles are possible instantly in
various locations,
and galleries gather to see the battles
.
By learning your master's battle style, you can
acquire techniques and master actions
.
Of course
, you can use them in fights,
but those techniques will also come in handy when navigating the city or exploring the
world.  In addition to the traveling story,
obtain and customize new items
World  Do Tour is a completely new way
to enter the world of
Street Fighter and experience the world of Street Fighter.
It will
be a place where you can enjoy communication By
sitting in the battle cabinet, you can
immediately and casually enjoy the battle hub
match.The experience is as if you were in an
arcade
.
We have prepared various items
Customize your avatar and have fun
You can play nostalgic titles on the game consoles
in the arcade Please look forward to what titles you can play
[Music]
Venue at the DJ booth  It is also possible to liven
up the game and take pictures at photo spots.We
have incorporated many playful elements.We are
developing the space called Battle Hub
as a place that everyone will want to visit every day.I am
looking forward to it.
Please watch this video at the end
[Music]
Thank you
for waiting.Street Fighter 6 closed beta test has been decided.You can participate during this period.You can experience the battle hub introduced today.
The
number of participants is limited, so
please check the official
Street
Fighter 6 website for the schedule and application details
.  Time Tomorrow
, Friday, September 16, from 24:00, a
special program of Street Fighter 6
will be broadcast.I will
tell you more detailed information that I could not talk about here, so please do not miss it.
This is the section where you can find
all kinds of information about Capcom
.
Go game  Introducing
Capcom's popular titles are on sale for a limited time to commemorate Tokyo Game Show 2022
Monster Hunter Rise 3 Break is on
sale for the first time
Monster Hunter Rise is
also on sale, so
don't miss this opportunity
Resident Evil Village, Capcom
Fighting Collection, etc.
Please check it out if
you missed the opportunity to play.
I'll tell you more detailed information that I couldn't talk about here,
so don't miss it.
And finally,
please watch the introduction video of the 4 Resident Evil series that will be distributed on the Nintendo Switch cloud version
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]  ]
That's all for today's
information. Please stay tuned
for information on Capcom's latest titles
.